ciao ragazzi e benvenuti alla terza
puntata di law con un e moggi questa
volta non parleremo delle cosi dal no mi
viene da una ragazza ma di tutte quelle
mossi inutilissime che ci sono che non
useremo mai io mi chiedo ma banchina
inventati cioè quando mai ho inviato una
roba del genere ci sono il giusto per
mason tipo questa che cos'è un diavolo o
un bambino cosa in rosso con la primiera
un leone diavolo è una figura mitologica
josè cosa mi rappresenta
interrogativo ma anche questa ok abbiamo
capito che piace il rosso a chi ha
creato le mogi quindi queste due
maschere o savadori è questa un maso
molto pronunciato che come si dice dalle
mie parti fa provincia però recente
quando ve lo dobbiamo fare
attendiamo la risposta ma a proposito di
voci che m l'ansia parliamo di queste
che cos'è utente facebook un omino non
si vede la faccia una cosa che mi sembra
chiedete i programmi con l'intervista
gli assassini potrebbe essere utile in
quei casi di rubano tutti i giorni degli
assi e inter visto che non vogliono
rivela tormenta tipo può essere solo
davanti non dietro vista molto con
quelli stalking quindi non ha orari su
di voi dimessa già rimandare le voci e
questo mi stanno solita quando non
creiamo neanche troppo chiudiamo il
capitolo lance andiamo avanti portiamo
andata allora tutti voi che a me
completa è capitato di andare a un
concerto di acquistare dei biglietti
quello del teoricamente concerto c'è
scritto sul tema the live concert e
ticket zona a per non farci mancare
niente però seguiva dal concerto certo e
sono nella zona c comunque è limitativo
questo lo dobbiamo dire cioè che quand
ribellati impuniti per avermi letto come
dio comanda ma ho selezionato anche
delle cose non inutili di più e cioè i
doppioni abbiamo dei campioni nelle
moggi people ad una parola luna c'è
restano brecce questa che quella
classica che ogni tanto si può votare e
poi ci sono queste una che si guardano
proprio si guarda ci parlano perché ci
sono due lune al mondo
no di testa e una di sinistra hanno la
faccia ed è molto albero azzurro non
sono guardavate ma comunque la grafica è
quella di non c'è cioè una jam java
schifo perché il tecnico sa luna voglio
vedere insomma adesso valuterà mai
ok nessun augura che motivo c'è chi paga
un'altra per non parlare delle lenti
lenti d'ingrandimento ce ne vorrebbe
fare una fan è una 2 2 una destra su una
che va verso l'interno
ma perché stessa cosa per i pupazzi di
neve c'è una piccola variazione basso
neve senza neve o un pupazzo di neve era
essenziale e o più capaci nere cioè
quando c'era in quel momento non stiamo
evitando non avrei niente nessuno perché
farle due perché sprecare nello spazio
ma parliamo anche di lei la spirale
allora se fosse di un colore di poe
mattoncino potrebbe essere uno zampirone
comunque l'estate si usa e blu che cos'è
cos'è un ghirigoro una cornicetta
pericolo di cornice adeguata
elementare ecco quella non ha senso
buttare lì così una spirale
parliamo del civismo
allora ci sono due ciclisti maschio
femmina perché non siamo razzisti contro
l'altro sesso senza sfondo c'è ciclisti
maschio e femmina di montagna al mare
secondo idc i ciclisti al mare non si
allenano non corrono non faccia perché
perché non sbaglia sia il mare no che
cos'è questo come se ci sto di comfort e
il mare io sto delineando il profilo di
viste le voci mister emo oggi è un uomo
che non gliene frega niente della moda
dopo capire perché che hanno la montagna
e l'isolamento e l'ansia gli animali ci
sono tutti e va bene le faccine le voci
sono tutte va bene a cosa serviva fare
appendere contro 2 3 4 5 6 8 facce di
gatti uguali alle farcelo l'elemosina
male però c'è quello che bianche cioè
quello innamorato c'è quello che ride
cioè quello malizioso c'è quello che dal
bacio senza il cuore con la rai ma anche
problemi signor moggi cioè legato ai
gatti benissimo ma era necessario fare
88 gatti che che hanno le stesse vecchie
perché è uguale io mi chiedo per quale
motivo io voglio mandare la pagina
morata un po emotivo domandare il gatto
innamorato
ci sono 200 miliardi i veicoli 7
frecciarossa
ora i giornali aerei che decollano un po
ma non tutti
trovassi sponsor semafori qualsiasi cosa
e apriamo l'armadio delle voci cioè
parlando di moda deboli a parlare di
vestiti femminili
abbiamo soltanto dopo proprio il kimono
perché comunque cioè dell'armadio di
tutte le donne italiane ultimo cioè ci
mancherebbe capito mancheremo
dall'oriente
allora io mi e ma questo è un appello
che faccio allora ci avete messo fino a
letto secoli che non provano le palle il
dito medio
facciamo un appello questa una petizione
b inflitto firmare questa petizione
apriamo l'armadio l'outfit possibili di
delle moto ok io sono riuscito a
concedere alla moda sono una persona
quanto appassionata di moda
tutti siamo molto bassi momenti moda
quindi mister emo oggi veramente stare
al passo con i tempi
voglio come minimo un tubino nero un
tubino nero non è che chiedo la luna 6
st pondaco le scarpe
cos'è questo sandalo
date gesù di nazaret colpa o o della
décolleté rossa cioè va bene carina ci
può stare qualche occasione ma mettetevi
è un'arte colte nera cioè il classico il
classico vuole metterle 3 cagate mette
almeno quelle del colore giusto che il
vestito azzurro cioè manco aurora la
bella addormentata ma concludiamo in
modalità meteo mi sento molto
metereologica oggi quindi sento molto
giù william ci sono la figlia digitale
giuridici e vorrei parlare di queste due
cose allora la nebbia e il vento
fondamentale cioè tutti i giorni col ti
sei svegliato e ha mirato di milano
quindi nebbia piazza come luogo comune
tutti i giorni diamo questa e la milano
dice movimentiamo questo modo si apre il
vento a oggi cosi come il tempo in un po
diventa emanerà tipo di soffia il vento
molto botticelli come wood molto
primavera di botticelli se credono il
video mette the like al video
iscrivetevi al canale e seguimi su tutti
a the social facebook ad ora
[Musica]